Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So, da bin ich.
Test.
Tut.
Ja.
Kewo, danke schön für den Sub.
Exquisite.
IIQ Subscription.
Das machen wir dann heute mal an.
Ich will zu entspannen gerade.
Machen wir mal wieder hier unsere...
Meine Lieblingsplaylist an.
War vorher sogar in Frankfurt und Hanau.
Exzellent.
Und hast du überlebt?
Geht's weiter? Ja!
Heute machen wir tatsächlich etwas
advancederes, würde ich sagen.
Weil ich meine, lernen bringt ja nichts,
weil man immer nur so easy Sachen und Sachen,
die man im Prinzip eh schon irgendwie hinbekommen würde und macht.
Heute probieren wir mal, wie man JSON-Responses macht mit Spring Boot,
wie man Websockets macht mit Spring Boot.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Und also im Prinzip habe ich mir gedacht, wir machen irgendwie so eine,
wir zapfen irgendwie einen der 3000 verschiedenen Public-Test-APIs,
die es da so gibt, an, so irgendwelche
Zitat-APs, Star Wars-AP,
Pokémon-AP, keine Ahnung, gibt es ja ganz
viele, und
ziehen da per Background-Job
irgendwie
alle 10 Sekunden oder so
ein neues Zitat und pushen
das dann per Websocket
auf unseren Client.
Dazu muss ich Websockets in Spring Boot lernen
und ich muss gucken, wie man JSON-Responses
macht, wie man HTTP-Requests
macht in Java.
und wenn das alles viel viel einfacher geht als ich mir das jetzt so vorstelle kann ja
rein gerade mit der hilfe vom chat chat liegt ja prinzipiell die falsch noch nie erlebt leute
oder hat hatte schon einmal erlebt dass der chat falsch liegen oder ich nenne das kann also gerade
was bei progast themen angeht das ist immer first try fehlerfrei für immer wenn das wenn das zumindest
das first try fehlerfrei für immer ohne probleme funktioniert dann gucken wir
noch wie man eine sql-datenbank anbieten das glaube ich aber nicht dass wir das
heute schaffen ich hoffe sind mit http requests websockets und background
threats und so schon genug beschäftigt ich weiß noch nicht ich habe ich habe
nicht einmal multi treten java aber leute ich habe doch letztens im stream
gesagt, so sinngemäß, ich kann es ja
nicht mal 100%ig sagen, im letzten Stream, wo es
schon hier mit Springboot und Java ging,
habe ich doch gesagt,
sinngemäß, ähm,
Java kann ich lesen und ein bisschen was
schreiben drin, aber Springboot
habe ich noch, habe ich gar keine
Ahnung und Java eigentlich auch nie groß
was mitgemacht. So.
Und wisst ihr, was mir da aufgefallen ist?
Ähm,
guckt mal,
ich habe doch hier
das Skills-PDF von meiner
Bewerbung.
Und da habe ich zufälligerweise mal reingeguckt
und da ist mir aufgefallen,
guckt mal, bei
Programmiersprachen steht Java drin.
Ich glaube, ich wollte da Kotlin
schreiben, weil in Kotlin haben wir
schon mal was zusammen gemacht im Stream.
In Java eigentlich nicht. Der Rest stimmt
ja alles. Der Rest ist alles richtig.
Also hier, das haben wir ja alles
im Stream sogar schon gemacht, aber Java?
Ja, hatten wir jemals schon
Ja, aber...
Ich glaube nicht, oder?
Egal, Hauptsache mal reingeschrieben.
Der Rest stimmt ja. Groovy stimmt auch.
Das ist meine einzige Sprache
mit ein bisschen Kotlin zusammen, wo ich auf
die JVM mal was gebastelt habe. Da habe ich mal was für Confluence
gebastelt in Groovy.
Naja.
Der Rest stimmt. Den Rest kann ich ja sogar
beweisen hier im Stream. Aber alles schon
im Stream gemacht. Was ich da alles...
Das ist übrigens nicht die
finale komplette Liste.
Das ist die, die wir hier mal im Stream erstellt haben.
ich hab die noch ein bisschen hübscher gemacht
als das, was ich hier jetzt liegen hab, ja
ups, warum danst der Pepo eigentlich
die ganze Zeit da immer noch rum
ja, das ist ein bisschen
weniger und ein bisschen
wilder zusammengeschrieben als das, was ich
dann da wirklich hingeschickt hab
aber im großen Ganzen
ist das zu 95% das, was
ich hingeschickt hab
ja, ja, und dann ist mir aufgefallen, da steht
einfach mal Java drin
ich mein, da steht auch C++
drin, das kann mir keiner vorwerfen
dass ich noch kein C++ gemacht habe,
beziehungsweise überhaupt keine Ahnung von C++ habe.
Dafür haben wir schon viel zu viele
C++ Streams gemacht.
Was da drin ja nicht steht ist,
ob ich das gut oder schlecht finde.
Steht einfach nur, dass ich mich damit auskenne.
Aber
nicht, ob ich es gut oder schlecht finde.
Hier steht einiges drin, was ich nicht so tolle finde.
Haben wir eigentlich Kobol reingeschrieben?
Moment.
Wie, warum nicht?
Warum habe ich nicht Kobol in meine Bewerbung reingeschrieben?
Wir haben doch schon mal einen Kobol-Stream gemacht.
Da kenne ich mich besser aus als 99,99% der Weltbevölkerung mit Kobol.
Wie, du glaubst Kobol nicht?
Wirklich? Wie jetzt?
Chat!
Dante, sagst du etwa, ich lüge im Stream?
Pass auf, ich kann dir das sogar beweisen
Da, Kobold Stream
Bam
So viel hat sich seitdem in Kobold nicht getan
Guck hier, Kobold
Kobold Broggers in der besten Schriftart
Ist auch noch dabei
Richtiger Hacker Man
kompiliert leute
dazu der imochi support naja
richtig herr kaman manche das habe ich nicht habe ich nicht eingetragen das ist auch so
So ein Nischen-Ding.
Doch, das war Weihnachts- oder Silvester-Stream.
Kobol.
Ja, ja, ja.
War's.
Übrigens, Chat.
Ich hab jetzt...
Ups.
Geht das nicht?
Ich muss mal kurz was checken.
Wo ist IntelliJ?
Da.
Chat, Chat.
Ich weiß, ihr versprecht mir nicht hinzugucken, aber...
ich muss euch trotzdem mal kurz ausmachen.
Ich hab mal was
checken.
Ähm.
Was immer.
Ich bin gerade verwirrt.
Okay.
Ich mache euch wieder an.
So.
Ähm.
Chat, ich bin hochgradig verwirrt.
Ich habe mich jetzt
eingeloggt in der JetBrains Toolbox.
Und ich habe immer noch keine Ultimate.
Ich soll irgendeine Trial starten?
Muss ich die vielleicht nochmal reinstallen?
Ich habe das All-Desktop-Pack.
Wir uninstallen IntelliJ Ultimate nochmal.
Die scammen hier.
Ist das nicht mehr da drin?
Ist das...
JetBrains All...
All Products, ja.
Da ist...
Ist doch drin!
Ja!
Ich bin eingeloggt.
Ich hab mich extra eingeloggt vorhin.
Wir machen mal ein Update
und danach installieren wir IntelliJ nochmal neu.
Das hat bestimmt gebackt.
Das hat bestimmt gebackt, weil ich die installiert
hab, wo ich nur nicht eingeloggt war.
Splixa, danke schön für den Sub.
Max, synkst du eigentlich Joplin
über die gehasste Nextcloud?
Ne, aktuell
synk ich das gar nicht.
Aber wenn ich
synken würde, dann wahrscheinlich.
Chat, wir müssen
uns morgen ein Video angucken.
Ich mach das schon mal auf
Das wurde mir empfohlen
Wartet mal, ich muss mal kurz gucken
Ähm
Ich hab's in meiner YouTube History
Das ist wieder ein Video
Opa Max erzählt vom Krieg
Ah, das wirst du uns morgen früh angucken
Moment, wo hab ich's denn
Ähm
Hä? Wo ist das denn? Hm, ich find's net.
Das ist ein Video, so geht Internet von 1993 oder sowas.
Sag mal, warum hat YouTube eigentlich diese blöde Angewohnheit, Videotitel zu übersetzen?
Das finde ich voll nervig.
Ach, du warst auf Twitter.
Ne, ne.
Also die einzigen, die mich auf Twitter gebannt haben, war MSI.
hier wdr computer club von 1999 internet das muss uns morgen mal angucken wie kommt man in
die ins internet genau da kann ob er max wieder was vom krieg erzählen die auto translate ist
übelst nervig übrigens leute nachher wenn ich hier fertig geschrieben bin wird wird eine runde
gerannt wieder für zeit dass ich wieder mal regelmäßig rennen gehe hier ich
dieses rum gehänge den ganzen tag bestimmt jetzt wieder ich habe zwei
monate fast nichts mehr gemacht das heißt ich brauche jetzt wieder vier
monate bis wieder auf dem stand bin von vor zwei monaten naja vielleicht
bisschen übertrieben aber dauert immer ganze ecke länger bis man das wieder
hat. So, jetzt installieren wir
mal
IntelliJ Community Edition.
Nein, wir installieren
IntelliJ Ultimate.
Jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
IntelliJ so gut.
Die ganzen Jetbrains-Dinger sind gut.
Also ich benutze ja hier ausgiebig
diesen ganzen Krempel, ja, von denen.
Und ich muss sagen,
also
das Einzige, wo man sich vielleicht
ein bisschen drüber beschweren könnte, dass das Zeug
alles rammfrisst wie sonst was,
ist nicht
Radfahren besser, bevor es wieder Winter wird?
Ne, ich geh ne Runde rennen. Kein Bock.
Kein Bock. Fahrradfahren finde ich
lohnt sich für eine Stunde nicht.
Aber
viel länger, eine Stunde
hier einmal quasi mal
am Einlagen und so, das geht, aber
Stunde für eine Stunde Fahrradfahren bringt nichts,
weil ich brauche ja schon eine halbe
Stunde, bis ich hier so mal
aus der belebteren
Gegend raus bin.
Und das lohnt
sich nicht. Also Fahrradfahren lohnt sich eigentlich
unter zwei Stunden nicht.
Webstorm
fand ich jetzt auch nicht so geil.
Das stimmt.
Webstorm habe ich mir auch mal angeguckt und da habe ich mir gedacht,
ne, brauche ich nicht. Bleibe ich bei Visual Studio Code.
Unlock Ultimate?
Warum?
Was ist das?
Ich habe ein Abo!
Guck mal, sonst könnte ich
ein Rider gar nicht verwenden ohne Abo.
Ich bin auch eingeloggt.
Ich kann jetzt nicht draufklicken, weil ich nicht Zeug
leaken will, aber
Moment, brauche ich...
Hä?
Ich habe
ein Abo.
Sonst könnte ich C-Line und das Ganze
verwenden.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Leute, ich logg mich jetzt mal kurz hier auf den zweiten Rechner.
Ich mache mal kurz hier
mein Clipboard aus, dass ich nichts leake.
Moment, das Clipboard, ich hab das Clipboard wieder angeschaltet, es war schon aus, lul.
Was?
Mein Abo ist nicht abgelaufen.
Das verlängert sich einmal im Jahr, kostet 179 Euro oder irgendwie sowas.
Sekunde, ich log mich mal kurz hier.
Jet Brains Login, das kann ich euch mal sagen, was ich hab.
Jet, was ist das?
jetbrains.com
Login
Wartet mal
Muss ich jetzt mal gucken, weil das nervt mich jetzt schon wieder. Was ist das hier? Jetbrains
Okay, continue
Nein, das ist das falsche, was ich hier kopiert habe. Copy Password, Login
Ich hab All Products Pack.
All Products Pack.
Billing Date 19. Juni 2026 wird's wieder gebildet.
Following products included.
IntelliJ Idea Ultimate.
Hä?
Was ist das?
Das check ich nicht.
Ich bin doch eingeloggt.
Ja, ich bin eingeloggt.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
steht sogar hier dabei guck chat ich
kann man das kann man nicht irgendwie mal ein paar sachen unkenntlich machen
das geht natürlich nicht das wäre zu einfach
zack ich zeige euch das guckt hier
kurz hier guckt dass ich nichts leake
ja
Guck.
Seht ihr das?
Also.
Weiß nicht.
Ich hab mich gerade erst eingeloggt in der Toolbox.
Name Leak Max K.
Ja, super krasser Leak.
Ich heiß...
Jetzt ist es raus.
Ich heiß einfach nur K mit Nachnamen.
Guck, und hier unten steht sogar,
dass IntelliJ Ultimate dabei ist.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Was ist denn das?
Ich muss nicht Ultimate unlocken.
Okay, ich hab ne Idee
Das Ding hat
Das Ding hat das bestimmt nicht gecheckt
Wir machen jetzt hier
Wir uninstall
Warte mal
Wo speichert denn dieses
Dieses Jetbrains Zeug
Wo speichert denn das Infos
IntelliJ oder so
Wo liegen denn hier die Daten rum?
Tja, ich weiß nicht
Reboot bringt da auch nichts
Sieht man irgendwie, wo hier die Daten liegen?
Ach hier
Local Share Jetbrain-Zubehör-Apps
Ja, Moment, das ist die
Aber ich suche doch die Config
Ich suche doch die Config
Das will ich mal alles löschen
J, Config, Home Directory
Das Ding hat sich wahrscheinlich
irgendwas gemerkt
was
configuration directory hier linux config jet brains ok config jet brains
wow
Alter
ähm
IntelliJ
haben wir sonst noch irgendwas
ja
ok
bam
gucken wir mal
ja
wir
wir skippen im Port
Ah, das sieht glaube ich schon besser aus
New Project
Activating Subscription
Hab das gelesen
Einfach mal die komplette
Config gelöscht, schon geht's
Jetzt kann man nämlich sogar hier ein Spring Boot Projekt anlegen
Das ist das, was ich letztens gesucht habe
Was nicht funktioniert hat
So sieht's aus
Pogu
Force Champ.
Also, dann machen wir das doch mal hier.
Hast du was mit Kotlin gemacht?
Ja?
Ja, ja. Ich finde es auch
angenehmer als Java. Zumindest das, was ich
letztens gesehen habe. Also, ich habe ja erst
einen Java-Stream gemacht.
Deutlich angenehmer. Aber, also,
der Grund, vielleicht sage ich das nochmal.
Der Grund, warum ich ein bisschen
Java lernen will, ist folgendes.
Auf der Arbeit
kann man mal so
so eine Art Praktikum
machen in anderen Abteilungen.
Und ich habe gesagt, ich würde gerne mal 14 Tage
zu unseren Entwicklern.
Und die
programmieren dann hauptsächlich in Java. Und ich habe mir gedacht,
bevor ich das mache, wäre es vielleicht
sinnvoll, wenn ich ein bisschen Ahnung von Java habe.
Und dann sagen wir mal, ein bisschen mehr als das, was ich schon
habe.
Deswegen basteln wir ein paar kleine Sachen jetzt in Java.
Und dann
kenne ich mich damit so weit aus,
dass ich vielleicht die ein oder anderen kleinen Sachen machen kann.
nicht lange keine ahnung wie lange ich da hingehe 14 tage drei wochen oder so
was ich mir an wieso
also jetzt mal also belegen jetzt war ein projekt an
kek weh champ
geht repo braun man nicht wir machen wir machen maven language java group
w punkt wo blitz group ist ja sowas wie eine namespace gier da kam unique
identifizieren project ja sowas fast sowas in der richtung
jdk 25 java version 25 das ist der unterschied zwischen war und ja
ist war ist das web assembly ja ja ja wollen wir haben
so und jetzt will ich gleich dieses dieses webstarter template hinzufügen geht das hier
hier? Aha.
Was? Lombok.
Was?
Reduce Boilerplate Code.
Ja, das ist gut. Aber nicht übertreiben.
Nicht übertreiben. Hier.
Spring Web.
Ist das das Starter?
Mach Lombok. Warum? Ich weiß nicht mal, was das ist.
Ist Spring Web
das Starter?
Nee, egal. Wir machen mal nix hier mit Dependencies.
Start.
Ja.
Ich mach erst Vereinfachungssachen,
wenn ich halbwegs checke, was es gibt.
Gibt's hier sowas wie Websocket?
Ah, guck mal da.
Builds Servlet-based Websocket.
SockJS und Stomp.
What? Kann ich nicht einfach stinknormals
Websocket benutzen?
Was ist SockJS und Stomp, Alter?
Was soll das sein?
Okay, wir machen einfach...
Ok, mal 356.
Gestern gab es noch 355.
Kann das sein?
So, create.
Zack.
Da sind wir.
Help.
Wir brauchen Help.
so ich würde sagen wir kopieren uns jetzt mal kurz die sache von gestern da rein wobei kopieren
uns die sache von gestern ist doch eigentlich egal wir können wir machen das einfach machen
das neue so als erstes muss man aber kurz von kontur umstellen und sei es und sowas editor
und wo ist es noch mal und da von sony jet planes mono sondern heck und zwar heck 16 dann erkennt
man ebenso was das ist glaube ich ganz gut color scheme und so das kann so bleiben da habe ich
keine schmerzen mit ist okay genau und jetzt müssen wir hier noch in die
pomp xml das habe ich auch gestern gelernt vom xml ist so was wie das die
project projekt datei in dotnet wo man nur dass man unter mit dotnet
nuget packages ordentlich installieren kann hier über die idee das habe ich
jetzt noch nicht gefunden aber vielleicht geht es jetzt weil jetzt habe
ich ja eine vollversion von intellij das probieren wir jetzt mal wie ging das jetzt hier nochmal
generate die pendel sie jetzt kann man nach starter suchen okay es funktioniert immer
anders sein dass ich da erst noch in den settings irgendwas einstellen muss dass
man erst quasi noch mehr von repo dinge wie hieß das ding maven central hinzufügen muss
also kann man vielleicht vielleicht die settings davon springen das ist herbst
Da steht Add Startups
Was wo? Add Startups?
Ach da, ja du hast recht
Aber trotzdem, die Suche muss doch eigentlich
Gescheit funktionieren, hm?
Ähm, Maven
Ach was suche ich da?
Ah ja, hier, guck mal
Ah, Kataloge
Aber Maven Central ist drin.
Repositories.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Wir kopieren das wieder von Hand.
Aber guck mal hier.
Ad Starters.
Was haben wir da?
Das ist ja schön und gut, aber...
Daniel Lull,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ähm.
Da wäre ich jetzt nicht schlau draus.
Wir machen das so, wie ich das gestern gelernt habe.
Wir gehen nach...
War das überhaupt gestern?
Oh, Leute. Wisst ihr was?
Ich muss euch mal was...
Wahrscheinlich was Ekliges
für euch erzählen.
Also erstens was nicht so Ekliges.
Mir juckt der Rücken.
Und es liegt daran,
ich war am Donnerstag
beim Hautarzt und hab
einen kleinen Leberfleck rausgeschnibbelt
bekommen. Und da ist jetzt so ein großes
wasserdichtes Pflaster
drauf.
Und das juckt
wie Sau da drunter.
Immer wenn ich nicht dran denke,
fängt es wieder an zu jucken. Und wenn ich dran denke, merke ich,
dass es juckt, dann denke ich, okay, jetzt geht's mir, dann denke ich wieder
nicht dran.
Voll abartig.
So, und jetzt, wo
es vielleicht ein bisschen eklig wird,
Der hat gesagt, ich soll nach Möglichkeit aufpassen, dass die ersten Tage gar kein Fall irgendwie Wasser dran kommt.
Und nach Möglichkeit soll ich mich nicht waschen da am Rücken oder nicht duschen auch.
Das heißt, ich werde jetzt wahrscheinlich bis Montag mich nicht unter das Wasser stellen.
Das heißt, Donnerstag, ganzen Tag nicht wäschen, Freitag ganzen Tag nicht, Samstag und Sonntag, also 4,5, 5 Tage.
Also wäschen darf ich mich, aber ich darf mich ja nur in die Dusche stellen.
Also nur wäschen mit dem Waschlappen und so darf ich.
Ich darf halt, muss halt nur aufpassen, dass auf meinen Rücken kein Wasser kommt.
Also mal spätestens am Montag
Ich muss mal
Ich muss aber auf jeden Fall mal
Mein Kopf unter den Wasserhahn oder so
Weil mir juckt der Kopf schon
Ja
Was man nicht alles macht für die Gesundheit
So hier also das brauchen wir
Das haben wir ja gemerkt
So kann man das einfügen
Im Prinzip
Für die ganzen Java Kenner unter euch
Ich zeig euch jetzt mal wie das in .NET funktioniert
Nur, dass ihr das einfach mal gesehen habt, weil ich finde, das ist in Rider viel schöner gelöst.
So, machen wir mal hier irgendein Projekt auf, ein .NET Projekt.
Äh, Don't Send.
Okay, die Schriftart ist vielleicht minimal zu groß, ja.
Ja, aber dann sieht man wenigstens was.
Guck, dann geht man hier hin, sagt Nougat.
Hat dann hier so eine Suche.
Und dann sucht man zum Beispiel hier irgendwie nach
Spectre Console.
Das ist so was, wo man dort nicht die
Konsole...
Machen wir Preview-Version aus.
Und dann sage ich hier Spectre Console
hinzufügen zum Projekt. Install. Fertig.
So. Und jetzt kann ich hier
Spectre Console
verwenden. Das ist alles.
Also da muss ich sagen,
das ist mir deutlich lieber als dieses gebastelt hier mit der prom xml moment
wo musste man jetzt noch mal klicken dass er das installiert hier oder was
jetzt passiert monka ist hier oben muss ich klicken
zink maven changes ok so jetzt haben wir jetzt können wir unsere web anwendungen
programmieren jetzt gehen wir noch einmal in das projekt ach so dass er
immer da das projekt von gestern repos kqs service und wir kopieren und smart kurz controllers
controller moment moment
Moment.
Das ist...
Das ist das Tottenham-Projekt.
Spring Boot Champ.
Da.
Source.
Main.
Java.
Cake.
Alter.
What the...
Warum ist denn diese Fahrt so lang?
Also in Ryder funktioniert das mit Nuga ziemlich gut.
Wie man sonst 3000...
Stimmt eigentlich.
Wenn das einfach funktionieren würde, dann wäre das ja easy.
So, das brauchen wir jetzt hier.
Ich will mir einfach nochmal rauskopieren, wie wir das gestern gemacht haben, dass man einen Restendpunkt hatte.
Wohin habe ich das kopiert? In diese Application rein.
Also quasi so.
Ups, ja, geh mal weg.
Gibt es sowas wie Auto-Format?
Format? Reformat-Code? Ja, wunderbar.
Get Mapping. Zack. Import.
Sehr schön
Producers Media Type
Images, ne
Producers Media Type, gibt es JSON?
Ne
Dann lassen wir das
Slash
Unter Slash wollen wir eigentlich jetzt eine Index HTML
Ausliefern
Gleich mal checken, wie das funzt mit einer Index HTML
Übrigens und
Ich hab gelesen
Dass
Es ist irgendwie verpönt, aber gefühlt macht es jeder
Die meisten Leute schreiben hier einfach
an ihre Methoden ThrowsException dran
und somit bist du fein raus und kannst
verwenden, was du willst.
Deswegen babbeln bei allen Java-Anwendungen auch immer
30.000 Exceptions hoch.
Habe ich das richtig verstanden,
Chat? Java-Kenners
unter uns? Einfach
ThrowsException überall hinschreiben.
Ein String kommt da zurück.
So, und jetzt ist die Preisfrage, wie kriegen wir jetzt eine HTML-Seite hier zurück?
das geht bestimmt also ich muss bestimmt nicht sagen file read all lines oder sowas oder das
geht bestimmt besser ok spring boot return index html display index per using controller das ist
doch schon mal als response body das habe ich jetzt so oft was ist der unterschied
zur request mapping versus get mapping difference between get mapping und request mapping ach so da
kann man was anderes hinschreiben als ach so ok get mapping ist quasi das gleiche wie request
mapping method get. Okay, ja gut.
Kannst du die Schriftgröße nach oben stellen? Hier ist zu klein. Ja, kannst du ein bisschen
größer machen. Da machen wir 18, das wird aber schon ganz schön fett jetzt. So ist gut, oder?
So, wie returne ich denn?
Display Index,
HTML Page Using, Add Controller.
Ah, Moment, das muss ich noch machen.
Äh,
Add Rest Controller.
Rest Controller?
Wirklich?
Ich will eigentlich kein Rest Controller.
Ich will Controller.
Weil ich will ja eigentlich gar keinen Rest-Endpunkt
Ich will HTML
Soll ich returnen
Übrigens
Das ist in .NET auch deutlich einfacher
Da würde ich einfach sagen
Use File Server
Ich denke mal
Sowas gibt es in Spring nicht
Da würde ich sagen, use File Server
Und dann wird alles gesurft, was in www-Root liegt
die move response von mir controller aber muss einfach nur index was man moment
ok also rest controller ist schon mal verkehrt ich will auf jeden fall controller weil ich
will kein jason gedöns machen so und jetzt sage ich index okay dann sagt man einfach nur return
index jsp ich will html return okay schauen wir mal ob das jetzt von ich habe keine ahnung
und etwas index aber riebkurs mapping slash klinger guter kann wobei eigentlich wollen
wir mehr ping haben get mapping slash so return index aber der return doch jetzt
den string index und nicht etwa einen ich habe ja gar kein index html
machen wir mal ein ordner hier sauce
directory www root ich nenne es jetzt einfach mal so ja so und das war hier html file index.html
kecke unter resources ach so nee oder gucken wir mal wir gucken mal was jetzt passiert wenn ich
das hier starte shift f10
80 80 ok aber ich starte mal hier chrome localhost 80 80
Sollte jetzt nicht zumindest irgendwas da zurückkommen?
Cannot resolve.
Ja, aber der sollte doch jetzt zumindest mal einen String returnen, oder?
Weil als mindestens.
Aber doch, der sollte jetzt zumindest mal einen Text returnen, oder?
Okay, vielleicht, wenn ich das so mache, dann...
Das ist der Unterschied zwischen REST-Controller und...
Ach so!
Das heißt, REST-Controller macht automatisch JSON-Gedöns
und Controller versucht, eine HTML-Datei zu finden.
Achso, okay.
Der sagt hier,
Cannot resolve MVC-View-Index.
Guck mal nochmal, was IntelliJ
da vorschlägt.
Ja, ne.
Beheben kann er das auch nicht.
Wo mussten denn die Views hin?
Index HTML.
in resources static okay
der hat hier eine extra my app structure ist das ist aber anscheinend verkehrt
Ich habe jetzt nicht gecheckt, woher der weiß, in welchem Ordner die Dateien liegen.
Okay.
Spring boot where to put index.html.
Hör mal noch richtig.
Proper location for HTML files.
source main resources public aha ok static static klingt gut static also die sources static
Oh jetzt haben wir krass Refactored, Alter.
Wahrscheinlich muss ich auch index.html schreiben, kann das sein?
Ha!
Kunst!
Okay, das ist zwar ein bisschen Magic.
Magic.
Aber wenn man weiß, wie es geht,
dann...
Production ready, ja.
Let's ship it.
0W.
Chat, warum reloadet er die Seite nicht?
Ist sie irgendwie
embedded oder so? Moment, ich muss
das neu starten,
wenn sich der Inhalt von HTML ändert?
Ja,
naja,
das ist vielleicht ein bisschen
doof,
aber gut, ist halt so, ne?
gibt schlimmeres macht nichts das macht nichts das meili hallo das macht nichts das ist nicht
das was ich weiß ich wollte mal gucken wie man hier html seiten wie man html sachen ausliefert
also dann gucken wir doch mal wie wir einen jason endpunkt machen dann muss ich bestimmt
eine neue Klasse anlegen. So, nennen wir das mal hier... Moment, gibt es hier etwas wie Generate und dann
Controller oder sowas? Spring Component... Aha, aha, aha, aha, guck mal da. Äh, tja. Ähm... Jason Controller.
controller ok request mapping slash api so machen wir einfach mal aber wir wollen get
hier so rest controller hat eine mapping und da wollen wir jetzt so was hier haben
So und da wollen wir jetzt mal eine JSON-Response raushauen
Wie hauen wir da jetzt eine JSON-Response raus?
Was passiert denn jetzt?
Warte mal, Shift-F10 für Restart
Was passiert denn jetzt, wenn ich hier mal einfach hinkörle?
Local Host
Ja und jetzt auf API
Inexact, ok da kommt der Text zurück
Und jetzt will ich Jason-Kram zurückgeben.
Hier, da gab es doch hier Response.
Response Body, was auch immer das macht.
Ach, das war ja eine Kombination aus.
Okay, das müssen wir uns mal angucken.
Spring Boot Return Jason Rest Controller.
Man kann doch bestimmt irgendeine Datei serialisieren lassen.
Also dass man jetzt zum Beispiel sagt, ähm, machen wir nochmal hier was.
Class, kann man das automatisch irgendwie generaten lassen?
Class, okay, Class, blub.
Äh, wie sieht denn das richtig aus in Java, so?
Äh, äh, okay, wie macht man dann Property in Java?
Wir machen, wir machen eine Public, Public Variable, okay.
Ähm, hier, int, 0 gleich 5.
beste und jetzt sage ich hier return new blub und das jetzt
ne club cannot be converted ok dann habe ich keine ahnung wie kannst
ja einfach ein object geht das kann ich so was hier sagen objekt oder so dann
geht das
status 406 not acceptable warum nicht was was will er von mir was wir sagen
das ist nicht acceptable objekt oder dass das kann so nicht sein
das ist noch acceptable weil ich weiß was plop type ist aber da oben steht es doch
okay das returning jason os responsible das wir lesen uns einfach mal durch wie das funst
jason objekt muss man da schreiben
das was anderes
der ist noch nie zu explizit konvertiert
return of pojo das mache ich doch
keine ahnung was
der törner ist von den jason formalia zeigt zeigt her
user response ok great rest controller wieso mache ich doch genau so mache ich das
das? Ah!
Produces Application
JSON Value muss da hin.
Aha!
Okay.
Das bringt jetzt Wasser, oder wie?
Ist immer noch, immer noch.
Oh, jetzt haben wir einen Internal Server Error.
Muss das nicht Path sein?
Anstatt
Internal Server Error.
Aber hier machen sie Value.
Ja, das check ich jetzt auch nicht so genau.
Ach nee.
Moment, aber das hat doch funktioniert,
als ich hier einen String returned habe.
Da ging das doch noch.
Ja, wenn ich den String return,
dann tut es doch.
Was hat er denn?
Ärgert den vielleicht, dass...
Okay, dann nehmen wir doch mal von ihm den Kram.
Public.
Kopiere das jetzt einfach mal.
Get Name.
Okay.
Eternal Sister.
So, so bleibt es jetzt.
Benutz mal Record, mach ich gleich, sobald es funktioniert.
Jetzt geht's!
Das war, weil die Klasse kein Property-Zeug hatte.
Ach so, okay, jetzt funktioniert's.
Ist aber doch eigentlich ganz gut gelöst.
Ah, oh, da liegt es an dem leeren Konstruktor.
Ist das nicht implizit default, ein leerer Konstruktor?
Doch ist es.
Ist es.
Das lag hier, dass die Klasse
nichts beinhaltet hat.
Okay.
Nutz mal Record.
Das gibt es auch.
Also quasi Record.
Das erinnert mich tatsächlich
ein bisschen an C Sharp dann.
Hier, blub.
String Name.
Zum Beispiel.
Hä?
Äh.
But why?
Das ist doch irgendwie überflüssig.
Wenn man es leer haben will.
Weil Java, okay, verstehe.
Oh.
Plop in record. Plop cannot.
Was?
Plop cannot be applied
to given types.
Was?
Ach, ich muss was angeben.
Ach so.
Ja.
Cute Chat.
Macht Sinn.
Punz.
Ganz ehrlich, ich finde es gar nicht so schlecht.
Man könnte jetzt ein bisschen drüber meckern, dass das alles ein bisschen verbose ist und so.
Ich kann mir nicht merken, ob es verbose oder verbos heißt.
Aber das geht doch eigentlich.
Das ist doch eigentlich ganz gut gemacht.
Also so Boilerplate hält sich doch bis jetzt so halbwegs in Grenzen.
Das ist doch eigentlich ganz gut.
Also, jetzt wissen wir schon mal, wie man
JSON-Objects serialized.
Gut, dann
machen wir mal das, was ich eigentlich vorhatte.
Websocket.
Da bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt.
Gibt es einen Grund,
warum du das lernst? Ja.
Chat, ruckelt der Stream bei euch?
Ich sehe den, der Viewer-Account ist
krass am rumspringen.
Und das ist meistens
ein Zeichen
für...
Der View-Account
springt bei mir immer um 50.
Alles gut.
Ja, es ist auch keine
Frames gedroppt.
Man weiß eh nicht, was er für Schmerzen hat.
Macht Twitch wieder komische
Sachen.
Ja gut.
So, dann können wir das machen, was ich eigentlich ursprünglich vorhatte.
Wir gucken mal, wie man Websockets macht.
Wollen wir mal? Komm, wir fragen mal ChatGPT.
Ähm, Java Spring Boot Minimal Websocket, Socket Example with JS Client.
So, schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt sich Mist ausdenkt oder nicht.
Spring Boot Data Websocket
Das klingt schon mal sinnvoll
Websocket Configuration
Ad Handler
Kami, danke für den Sub
Websocket Handler
Ich glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert, oder?
Meine des Funds, was ist das da?
was es da generiert hat.
Gott, vier Videos.
Boah, Alter, das ist ja schon so lange her.
So, Websocket.
Also, das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt erst einmal hier Websocket.
Also, Starter Web.
Dann wollen wir jetzt...
Ne, wir müssen wieder in Maven Central.
Maven Central.
Und jetzt Websocket.
Starter.
Spring Boot Starter Websocket.
Also das ist jetzt nicht super eklig.
Ne, das ist falsch.
Das ist jetzt nicht super eklig.
Mit diesem XML gepaste.
Aber ganz ehrlich.
die Nougat Sache, die ich euch gezeigt habe,
war schon besser, oder?
So.
Jetzt haben wir hier
den können wir mal
kleiner machen.
Jetzt haben wir hier die Möglichkeit, unser
wollen wir mal gucken, ob das, was
ChatGPT sagt, ob das sinnvoll ist.
Weil das haben wir gemacht.
Ne, mit
AddStarter habe ich nichts gefunden.
guck, warte mal
Add Starters
da habe ich, wenn ich, ich sage
und wenn ich nach Starter suche, findet er aber nichts
obwohl ich Add Starters
gemacht habe
oder
ist WebSocket, ach das
ist das, die haben einfach nur das Ding nicht
Starter genannt
das sind alles Starter
deswegen haben die den Namen Starter
weggelassen, achso
SQLite, wie gibt es nicht
gibt es Postgres
ok jetzt haben wir websocket zeusch ich suche noch mal hier minimal websocket example spring boot
kleon wieder
Ja, ja, bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Stomp. Nein, nein, nein.
Ich will das Simpelste haben überhaupt.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was Stomp ist.
Jetzt macht es aber kompliziert.
Bonk AS.
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Gibt es nicht irgendwie so ein kleines, kurzes,
prägnantes Beispiel?
Ist ein Websocket-Protokoll.
Ich brauche einfach nur Text darüber, gut ist.
Spring Messaging.
Enable Websocket in Spring.
Stomp, schon wieder.
Komm, Chat, wir trusten jetzt Chat.
Wir trusten jetzt Chat GPT, wie das funktioniert.
Ich kopiere das jetzt einfach.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es funktioniert, ehrlich gesagt.
aber der websocket config figuren
bei websocket händler slash wie er sagt das klingt doch aber eigentlich ganz
ganz sinnig websocket händler tag
text websocket händler websocket session text messer ich importiere einfach alles
und diese funkt schon mal nicht weil
das aber doch kein error oder es wirklich ein error weil das kann doch
nicht sein dass es ein error ist
public das ist wirklich ein error naja muss ja nicht public sein
nicht public sein so moment wollen wir sagen das ist wirklich schon alles jetzt
websocket at at händler slash bs
ich weiß ja gar nicht ob ich das haben will
also laut chat gpt hubs laut chat gpt war es das jetzt mal gespannt ob das so stimmt
WS-Cat?
Nee, äh
WS? Ah ja, hier, okay
WS
Local Host
Host
80 WS
Was?
Was funzt?
Das war? Ja, das ist doch gar nicht so kompliziert.
Ganz ehrlich, das ist gar nicht so unterschiedlich zu ASP.NET Core mit Signal A.
Ich bin beim Battlefield 6 am Start, ja.
Max, ich habe eine Frage als Java-Noob.
Ja, komm, als bin ich der Java-Pro, Mann.
Warum rufst du die Plup-Funktion per Exception auf?
ist Exception. Hä? Was mache ich?
Ne, ne. Das heißt, dass
diese Methode eine Exception werfen
kann.
Warum nicht direkt Kotlin anstatt Java?
Das kann ich dir erklären, weil
bei uns auf der Arbeit so gut wie alles in Java
programmiert wird. Ich arbeite bei einer Versicherung,
Business Enterprise stellt, das ist alles
in Java und ich gehe
demnächst mal für 14 Tage zu unseren
Entwicklern und ich dachte mir, bevor ich
dahin gehe ich mache so ein internes man guckt sich mal eine andere abteilung an
praktikum bei uns intern oder dachte mir das macht schon sinn bis den jahr war zu
wissen bevor man da hingeht also das heißt was wir hier machen da
kommt nichts sinnvolles am ende raus außer dass man ein bisschen java und
springboot gelernt hat jetzt mal eine ganz doofe frage an euch wenn das hier
Ja, schon komplett ausreicht, um Websocket Kommunikation zu machen.
Was zum Teufel machen denn diese ganzen Anleitungen hier?
Mit Stomp und hast du nicht gesehen?
Wer braucht das überhaupt?
Sock.js Stomp?
Ne, der macht das ohne Stomp.
Moment, der macht das doch hier fast so wie ich, oder?
Text Websocket Händler.
Ja, das mache ich doch auch.
Der macht doch im Prinzip so etwas Ähnliches wie ich hier.
Guckt mal.
Der macht hier so eine...
Whatever.
Zeug.
Und dann?
Live Ping Event.
Ja, das ist das nächste, wie ich per Websocket Sachen hinschicke.
Aber das probieren wir gleich.
Da müssen wir jetzt so ein kleines JavaScript Frontend basteln.
Das brauchen wir alles nicht.
Der Websocket Konfigurer.
Und AdHandler.
Ja genau, im Prinzip ist es ja das, was ich auch gemacht habe.
das dann dann connecten wir uns da jetzt mal per javascript hin machen wir das hier mal zu
dann machen wir das mal dann gehen wir jetzt waren wir mal hier außerhalb von source machen
wir mal hier directory keine ahnung web app was denn unter target web app da gehen wir mal hier
nach rein nach i
was ist denn der real java champ
ah das war was was mein kotlin gebaut haben damals ich erinnere mich dunkel
also gehen wir mal hier hin web app und ja gut da war jetzt wohl studio code auf
dotnet gedönst mama ford getrusten web app müssen unser wish list studio code umstellen auf web
und dann legen wir mal ein index html an
mit einem standard template drin genau bla bla title 0w body copilot geh mal weg so und
da machen wir jetzt unser javascript zeug drinne. Machen wir hier mal den Browser auf. Achso,
Moment, Sekunde. Ne, wir machen das ohne, auf 8000. Wir machen das ohne Content Framework
oder sonst was.
Einfach nur hier die
Vanilla
JavaScript Zeug.
Also jetzt connecten
wir uns mal zu unserem Websocket.
Also
Moment, ich kann gar kein
Vanilla.js mehr basteln. Also, wie ging das
jetzt hier so? Script.
Console. Gucken wir mal, ob das
an sich wenigstens Funs, weil ich da mache.
Ja, okay.
Also.
Wo war das?
Was sagt
dein Chat-GPT, wie mein JavaScript-Client
aussehen soll? New Websocket.
Genau.
So.
Also.
Let WS
gleich. Warte mal. War es denn
überhaupt Let in JavaScript?
web socket auf wie es doppel punkt um sich localhost doppelpunkt 80 80 ps
hat noch gefunden wie es connect
auf ich weiß nicht
oder ist oder connecte das jetzt direkt wenn man das so macht
an die open kann man eine nachricht red red registern und message on close ja ok
ok die drei dinger sollten wir uns wahrscheinlich mal holen ja es macht schon sinn
Aber hier vs. Es war dieses TypeScript bonkers. Geh weg
Message
Connection open okay, connected
Log
Message
hier klaus okay jetzt haben wir hier jetzt können wir eine message schicken per websocket und dann
sollte die eigentlich auf dem kleinen rauskommen aktuell ist es so wie wir schicken einem ach nee
ich musste message senden dass ich der antwort bekomme okay dann machen wir das mal mama hier
in on open
ist das Arch
by the way
es ist Arch
aber in vm
in der vm
so
dann machen wir mal hier on open
Das ist die 3
Wayland in der VM funktioniert richtig
So und dann machen wir jetzt mal hier
WS Send
0W
Irgendwas, ist doch egal
Und wir bekommen ein Echo Event
Das ist ja viel einfacher, als ich mir das eigentlich gedacht habe.
Mit Websockets.
Also wir sind noch lange nicht fertig.
Ich will ja, dass das im Hintergrund automatisch updatet und per HTTP sich Sachen abruft von irgendeiner API und dann mir alle 10 Sekunden schickt und sowas.
Aber Lernst du WebDev jetzt?
Naja, gar so schlecht bin ich jetzt ja auch nicht, was Frontend-Sachen angeht.
Also wir haben ja schon die ein oder anderen Frontend-Sachen gemacht.
Ich bin jetzt hier kein Fulltime Frontend
Entwickler, aber so ein bisschen Ahnung
Von Frontend Sachen habe ich schon
Direkt in Lebenslauf
Du hast es am Anfang des Streams verpasst
Oder?
Ich hab das schon bei mir im Lebenslauf drinstehen
Alter Edge
Was willst du von mir?
Ich hab das schon im Lebenslauf drinstehen
Okay, so
Also, das Funst
Ich bin jetzt gerade bisschen
Bisschen verpeilt, Leute
Konnte man nicht
Wie ging das nochmal in JavaScript? Ich versuche gerade, ich habe mir gerade
überlegt, wenn ich hier unten weiter schreibe, ja, dass ich nicht so viel nested
Code habe. Ich würde gern so was machen wie await ws onopen, aber das funzt ja
nicht. Das muss man irgendwie mit promises machen, aber das ist glaube ich zu
kompliziert. Ich wollte eigentlich warten bis der connected ist.
Ich glaube da muss irgendwie sagen, irgendwie let you promise oder sowas.
Und irgendwie resolve.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Zumindest kann ich dann sagen, irgendwie await.
Ich check nicht, wie das von uns, aber egal.
Das können wir dann reinschreiben.
Jetzt haben wir doch eigentlich
freundetmäßig alles, was wir brauchen.
Jetzt will ich nur, dass automatisch
dass das hier, das hier
soll automatisch passieren.
Handle Text Message.
So, Handle Text Message wollen
wir gar nicht. Ich will, ich will
eigentlich das hier machen. Okay?
Ich will automatisch im Hintergrund alle 10 Sekunden was an den Client schicken.
Das heißt doch im Endeffekt, eine Websocket Session, After Connection Established, die muss ich mir irgendwo speichern, die Websocket Session.
Damit ich nachher da wieder drauf zugreifen kann.
Also heißt es im Endeffekt, ich brauche irgendwie sowas wie ein Dictionary.
Das heißt, in Java ist es HashMap, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe.
So, und da will ich einmal ein String und eine WebSocket Session haben.
Gibt es eigentlich in Java sowas wie eine ThreadSafe HashMap?
Wobei, der hat doch hier auch sowas, der Typ, oder?
Ach ne.
Ähm...
Java Threads...
Konkurrent Hashmap gibt es?
Hashmap.
Ah, sehr gut.
Wobei, brauche ich eigentlich eine Hashmap?
Eigentlich nicht.
Gibt es eine Konkurrent-List?
Was haben wir denn?
Konkurrent-Map? Konkurrent-Hash-Map?
Map-Linked?
Gibt es eine Konkurrent-List?
Weil wir nicht.
Machen wir einfach so. Zack.
Konkurrent-Hash-Map.
Sessions.
Das macht man garantiert in Java nicht so, oder?
mit dem Underscore.
Bestimmt nicht.
So.
Und jetzt sagen wir hier Sessions
and
nein, put ist es.
Put
getSessionIdSession.
Genau, das wollen wir haben.
Ja, ich will ja eigentlich auch
broadcasten. So, Handle Text
Message, das brauchen wir nicht.
Äh, Comment.
So. Wir wollen
eigentlich im Endeffekt, jetzt ist die Frage,
wie mache ich das jetzt
gescheit? Also wir machen es jetzt mal so,
wie man es auf jeden Fall nicht macht, weil ich
bin mir unsicher, wie ich das mache.
Ich will jetzt automatisch alle
den Sekunden was an den Client schicken.
Normalerweise hätte ich jetzt hier
irgendwie irgendein Background-Task.
So.
Und da müsste man dann...
Na gut, das muss einfach
Static und Public sein, oder?
Dann funzt das. Aber das ist bestimmt nicht so gedacht.
Das ist bestimmt nicht so gedacht.
static und public aber scheiß drauf war trotzdem jetzt was wird das wenn es fertig ist ich lerne
einfach nur java und spring gut also deshalb das hat keinen tieferen mehrwert am ende was
anwendungen rauskommt aktuell ist das ziel ich will per websocket alle zehn sekunden was an
einen kleinen schicken.
Okay, hier können wir uns
connecten gleich und dann sehen wir das.
So, und jetzt will ich sowas machen.
Jetzt will ich
im Endeffekt, wo haben wir hier
Main? Hier, Main.
So, und da will ich
sowas wie Task Run
oder sowas machen.
Moment, es gibt was, was Task heißt?
Ich mach das.
Ne, nix.
Ähm.
Ja, äh.
Java Task Run.
Du kannst dir einen
Scheduled Executor Service holen
Der dann alle x Sekunden
Dinge ausführt
Ja sowas will ich haben
Das klingt gut
Ist das was was bei Spring dabei ist
Ich kann übrigens gerade nicht mal copy pasten
Doch kann ich
aber okay spring boot schedule gibt es gibt es bestimmt auch was
scheduling task spring enable scheduling
Create a
Playung
Warum heißt die Seite Playung?
Ich verstehe es nicht
Ja, ich weiß, die heißt nicht so, aber so ähnlich
So, Schedule Task at Component
Okay, ich habe keine
All
Immer Annotations.
Das habe ich mittlerweile auch schon mitgekriegt.
Also Enable
Scheduling.
Muss man da machen.
Hauptsache Annotations.
Das finde ich auch teilweise ein bisschen übertrieben.
Und jetzt
einfach das hier?
jetzt sage ich quasi hier
Scheduled Task
hier Component
doch das, guck mal, warum soll ich
alles, guck mal, wir haben jetzt
noch nicht mal 100 Zeilen, warum soll ich
mich durch zig Dateien klicken, wenn ich
das im Prinzip alles fast schon auf ein Bildschirm
kriege
so, Scheduled brauchen
wir hier, sind das Millisekunden
Das kriegen wir nicht gesagt
Was
Bonk heißt
Sind das Millisekunden
Man weiß es nicht
Im Controller
Nein das gefällt mir nicht
Tja
Sind das Millisekunden
Es wäre halt nice
wenn es irgendwo stehen würde, dass es Millisekunden
sind.
Ganze Gelogger brauchen wir hier nicht.
Juckt mich null.
So, und jetzt machen wir was, was wahrscheinlich relativ eklig
ist. Hier, äh,
ich nenn's einfach mal Pink Client oder so.
So, jetzt machen wir was, was relativ
eklig ist, und zwar, weil ich hab keine,
ich hab keine Idee, wie wir's sonst hinkriegen.
Und zwar,
My Websocket Handler
Sessions.
Globale Variable für alle.
Das geht bestimmt schöner.
Ich habe aber immer noch keine Ahnung,
wie ich meine ganzen
Websocket Dinger von da
da rein bekomme.
Und jetzt will ich
eine Schleife da drüber machen.
For each?
4i? Ne.
Java for each.
Der hat ne List, aber ich will ne Threadsave-List haben.
Ah.
Aha.
Ah, ich will nicht String.
War.
Fange erst mit gar nichts anderem an.
My Websocket.
Sessions.
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
For each not applicable.
Applicable.
Ähm, okay.
Java.
Iterate.
Concurrent Hash Map.
Wie geht das?
Entry Set.
What?
was will er
ja jetzt der kaufler erzählen wir wie es geht values
was will er jetzt von mir also als public ist und jetzt wollen wir eigentlich dass auch nicht
hier session jetzt wollen was session punkt send message da müssen wir noch
mal in das beispiel hier reingucken
send message new text message aha new text message und dann irgendwie
irgendein Payload?
Was?
Was to string?
Char Sequence.
Er ist doch hier. Char Sequence.
Ne.
Unhandled Exception.
Wobei, ne Leute.
Das soll nicht crashen.
Es könnte ja auch sein, dass die Session mittlerweile geschlossen ist.
Da müssen wir jetzt wirklich einen Try-Catch drumherum machen.
Wie kann man hier einzelne Zeilen verschieben?
Da müssen wir wirklich einen Try-Catch drumherum machen.
Das kackt uns das Ganze ab.
Catch.
I.O.X.
IntelliJ ist nicht schlecht, oder?
Das ist nicht schlecht, IntelliJ.
Der schlägt uns gleich die Exception vor, die da gethrowt wird drinnen.
So
Das will er von mir
Perfekt
Wegschmeißen
Sehr gut
So, wenn ich jetzt alles richtig gemacht hab
Dann
Sollten wir jetzt
Alle 5 Sekunden
Bekommen wir die Textnachricht
Na
dazu kann ich ja nur sagen
easy
way too easy
doch es funzt auf Anhieb
oh es ist abgekackt
Websocket session has been closed
and no message
ja deswegen catche ich das doch auch
warum kackt
das jetzt ab
Warum ist das jetzt abgekackt?
Ich catche doch die Exception hier
Wo ist er denn abgekackt?
Ach ne, der ist gar nicht abgekackt
Der läuft immer noch weiter
Ah, verstehe
Das ist eine Logging, eine Log-Meldung von denen.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, das ist schon richtig.
Ich muss das jetzt ja noch löschen.
Ne, ne, die Hash-Map ist nicht leer.
In der Hash-Map ist eine Session drin, die wurde geclosed.
Ich muss jetzt noch sagen, on close oder irgendwie sowas.
Aber wie geht das jetzt hier?
Add, overwrite.
Hauptsache mehr Annotations.
Public, void.
Wobei, das kann man doch bestimmt,
bestimmt kann einem da IntelliJ helfen, oder?
Wie liste ich hier?
Override Methods.
Haha.
Close.
Irgendwas mit Close.
Bist du neu bei Java?
Ja.
Relativ neu.
Handle.
Also, das ist mein zweiter Stream mit Java.
Sonst habe ich nur ganz, also ganz, ganz wenig Java-Erfahrung.
Und Spring Boot gar nicht.
Wo ist denn hier?
After Connection Closed.
Das habe ich gesucht.
So, After Connection Closed.
Will ich.
Sessions.
Delete.
Ne.
Ja.
Remove.
Session ID.
Was hat er hier für Schmerzen?
Achso, falls es das nicht gibt.
Also, ja gut.
Aber was meckert er denn jetzt hier gerade an?
was hat was hat er jetzt für ich verstehe das problem jetzt gar nicht
0 ach so 0 weil es eine null point der exception geben kann wenn es den kino ich
gibt okay das macht in der tat tatsächlich dann sinn auch noch mal einen try catch zu rappen
aber was was will er denn hier was was was was warum ist das denn jetzt
oder gibt es drei remove
er will dass du so was wie ein using macht
den das geld der index in der ich brauche nicht den index das ist der
hash map ich brauche einen key den einzigartigen key ich bin ich bin jetzt
irgendwie gerade verwirrt was der google try with okay frei mit resources
Ja, aber hier, guck mal, IntelliJ mag ja nix.
Der bietet mir nix an, um das zu fixen.
Oder...
Try with resources statement.
Try...
What the...
Will der sowas haben?
Nee, oder?
Was?
Ich hab...
Returned das irgendwas?
Remove?
Was?
Was returned das denn?
Ach, die Session
returnt das.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, was der
eigentlich will, ehrlich gesagt, von mir.
Warum das unterkringelt ist.
Ich habe absolut keinen Plan.
Websocket Session used without...
Ach, jetzt weiß ich es, glaube ich.
Der will das
da von mir haben, oder?
Ach, sowas will er von mir haben.
Sowas ähnliches.
Ich checke aber nicht, wie es jetzt weitergeht.
Hä?
Also, seriously, kein Schimmer, was das Ding von mir will.
Wurscht.
So.
Bam.
Aber zumindest sollte das mein Problem jetzt fixen.
Dass der dann ewig rummeckert hier unten, wenn die Session zu ist.
jetzt gucken wir mal krieg ich alle fünf sekunden kriege ich was geschickt so jetzt
breche ich ab guck jetzt hat das jetzt kackt er hier nicht mal ab jetzt hat das direkt
entfernt schreiben wir hier noch noch rein closed connection so so ist gut ja das ist
nice, da brauchen wir dieses ganze Gedöns nicht.
So, und jetzt können wir unser Frontend reingucken.
Ach, den Wörter. Das ist doch echt nicht
schlecht. Also, ich muss sagen,
ich hab mir das schlimmer vorgestellt.
Das ganze Annotate ist vielleicht ein bisschen
nervig, aber ganz ehrlich,
wenn das alles ist, was man
für WebSocket-Handling braucht, dann
ist das doch echt überschaubar
und gut gemacht.
Was ich halt überhaupt nicht checke, ist,
warum die Beispiele
so krass bloated sind.
Ja, wenn du hier suchst
Spring Boot Websocket
Minimal Example
Da findest du dann solche Dinger
Die
100.000 Sachen machen
Irgendwelche Endpunkte
Und
Stomp
Was auch immer.
Und dann brauchst du irgendwelche extra kleinen Sachen,
dass es funktioniert.
Das will ich gar nicht.
Ich will einfach stinknormales Websocket haben.
So, dann machen wir das doch mal.
Wenn das Millisekunden sind,
alle 100 Millisekunden
will ich was geschickt kriegen.
Restart.
Gucken, ob das jetzt funzt.
Jetzt sollte uns das ganz schön die Konsole vollspammen.
Jawohl.
Sehr gut.
So.
Next.
Wie macht man HTTP-Requests?
Machen wir mal alle Sekunden.
Wir wollen die APIs jetzt nicht so krass vollspammen.
Ich finde das gar nicht schlecht, ehrlich gesagt, Leute.
Das ist ziemlich...
Also für Java-Verhältnisse ziemlich kurz und knackig.
Das Websocket-Handling hier.
kannst du dich nicht beschweren
so wirklich übersichtlich
so und jetzt kommt man wie man http request macht jetzt hat die api
wir suchen uns jetzt mal irgendeine api raus wo wir zeug für abfragen können
zur not nehmen die star wars api
tom hicks lucifer kurz habe ich geguckt die serie die war ich ganz neues
Harry Potter Quotes
Die Poké-RP, ja das ist... nein die Herr der Ringe-RP. Wir brauchen eine RP-Key?
The One-RP
Brauchen Keinen api wobei wobei das mit dem api ist gar nicht so blöd da können wir uns auch noch überlegen gleich wie es funktioniert
Wir Suchen uns Irgendeine ich weiß was quote in der quote anime quotes
Ja Genau das das ist das allerwichtigste das brauche
Die letzten Staffeln habe ich auch nicht geguckt.
Ich habe bei Staffel 4 oder so aufgehört.
Jason Placeholder.
Ich finde, das ist tatsächlich für unseren Fall gar nicht so verkehrt.
Free, fake and reliable API for testing and prototyping.
Patch to do...
Ja, das ist ziemlich gut. Das machen wir.
Ja, das ist gut.
Das benutzen wir und dann machen wir noch einen Timestamp.
Ja, das ist gut, das benutzen wir.
Wie viele To-Do's gibt es hier eigentlich?
Kann man das listen irgendwie?
hier hier sind alle alle to do's regenerate sich das irgendwie random
ich habe die idee was wir machen wir rufen einfach random 1 bis 10 ab das
schon okay so jetzt ist die preisfrage wie macht man in java http requests das ist eher das ist
eher keine spring boot frage sondern eine java frage oder web klein non blocking reactive klein
mit fluchen ab ihr rest klein moment sehe ich das richtig allein das spring
framework hat vier verschiedene http clients
und
ja
das ist ein kleines klein mit der flut ab sinken das klein mit template method
api prominent web non blocking reactive klein mit kluder in den restline restline klingt gut
alter ort
http-commons-client http-request-factory
mehr Java-Benahmung geht nicht mehr, Alter.
aber wir können einfach sagen rest client default create das schon mal gut
okay ich mache das mal in die main in meine main methode rein weil ich ganz ehrlich ich will ja
nur gucken wie man wie http request macht eigentlich kacken ob ich habe meinen clipboard
ausgeschaltet war war auch die programme am start http client http client jetzt
gibt es wahrscheinlich was aber dann noch so für methoden hier drin
get delete put add method mutate patch post ok get wollen wir haben wie macht man ein get request
so schon immer nett das wäre auch deutlich zu einfach
wie macht man einen weg
moment
man macht einen get und danach gibt man erst die url an wie macht denn ein get ohne dass er die
url weiß in den bildern bin ich jetzt bin ich ein bisschen leicht verwirrt
ok aber ich will platzhalter okay das kann dann machen wir so hier noch die
ID ist... Moment.
Ah, haha.
Das habe ich doch gestern gelernt, wie man random macht
in Java. Random.
Thread. Local.
Random. Ne.
Ah.
Current.
Next.
Int.
Von 1 bis
10. Keine Ahnung.
So.
ich weiß auch nicht warum das so kompliziert ist sind in den in sich zu rennen meisten in die aber
ich glaube müssen 11 nehmen weil das weil das inklusive 1 vermutlich und dann bis 11 also
inklusive 10 exklusive 11 oder einfach random next in das hat nicht funktioniert das habe
ich gestern ausprobiert das geht schon mal nicht next in
so id jetzt lädt er das runter
und jetzt geben wir uns das mal aus gibt es hier vielleicht ein makro für
out was war das system out print id
hat das im fonds das jetzt schon lass mal gucken
alle nicht print id was mache ich denn das bonn es bonn ist ein http herr speck
moment ich muss gucken wie man wie man den request macht bin dazu blöd für retrieved
muss man dann sagen. Aha.
Und dann was?
Body String Class.
Das ist aber wirklich jetzt alles andere
als intuitiv.
Machen wir mal so.
So.
Retrieve.
Was hat er für Schmerzen
wieder?
Result is ignored.
Ja, ja.
Sponsor.
response body kann man nicht sagen to string doch zu springen geht bestimmt auch response
to bodyless entity wie sich das anhört mal kurz
welche java version 25 to string guck mal was da jetzt rauskommt
kommt daten so geht das schon mal mit response body
ich finde das warum gibt es nicht so was wie es stringt das ist so ziemlich
wahrscheinlich was 99,9 prozent der leute wollen mit dem response
Okay, String, Punkt klar.
Das finde ich jetzt abartig, ehrlich gesagt.
Weil du Responses fast nie als String haben willst.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich will zu 99% meine Responses als String haben,
damit ich sie danach als JSON oder so parsen kann.
auf uns kannst auch string machen das bezweifle ich dass man so meint so wir
sind ja nicht in dort netter das von uns natürlich nett oder
Oh ne, ah, Moment, redo?
So, so will ich das haben.
Ach, ich kann da...
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich das.
Ich mache...
Ach so.
also eigentlich machen wir sowas hier wie ja keine api response sowas chat
wir machen ein rekord wieder ist doch viel besser records records string user id string
und id die string title moment war was hat er denn für schmerzen gerade was will er jetzt von mir
Achso der Name.
Api Response.
User ID, Int ID, String Title, Completed.
Bool.
Chat, was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Int und Int?
Ah ne, Int gibt es gar nicht.
Aber...
Ist eine Rapper-Klasse.
Warum soll ich ein Int rappen wollen?
Achso, das kann
null sein, das andere nicht.
Also das Gegenstück von sowas hier
in .NET quasi.
Also das ist in .NET, ist das ein Nullable
Int.
ok verstehe das heißt jetzt sage ich wenn ich das hier zum die sehr realisieren verwenden
will sage ich hier ab response punkt glas korrekt das ist doch eigentlich ganz cool
das ist gefällt ist ganz ehrlich das gefällt mir eigentlich ganz gut das ist ein bisschen
wie in .NET, wenn man sowas sagt,
dann hier irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
JSON-Response, Punkt,
wie war das jetzt nochmal,
nicht S, die Serialize irgendwie,
die Serialize
als
API-Response, so.
In .NET wird das so ungefähr ausschauen.
Also von der Gewöhnung her
finde ich das ja auch schöner,
aber das geht klar.
Also das geht echt klar, finde ich.
Kann man so lassen.
So, jetzt haben wir hier ein
randomizedes
eine randomizede
API-Response. Gut, dann
kopieren wir uns diesen ganzen Krempel mal
und starten wieder unsere
Spring-Anwendung
und gehen jetzt mal hier hin,
wo wir automatisch aktuell nur immer diesen sinnlosen Text senden.
So, wir wollen alle, einmal pro Sekunde,
wir wollen einmal pro Sekunde, wollen wir neues,
neue hier Fake-To-Dos abrufen.
Wir können das auch printen, das ist okay.
und dann wollen wir das ganze senden aber das nicht auf eine zeile macht
manchmal kurz format und jetzt sagen wir hier als payload
das kann man eigentlich alles machen hierbei bei send message
Ich will das als chasen senden, siehste?
Okay, wir tun jetzt mal so, als hätten wir was damit gemacht.
Wir tun jetzt mal so, als hätten wir was gemacht.
Also, ähm, wir nennen das Ding jetzt nicht api, also hier, nennen wir das mal anders.
Nennen wir das mal hier, ähm, hier todo api response.
und dann haben wir unseren Kram, das heißt hier, whatever hier, Frontend-API-Response oder so.
So, und unsere Frontend-API-Response sieht anders aus, wie das da ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Da gibt es noch einen Timestamp dabei bei uns hier.
Int-Timestamp.
So, einfach mal jetzt.
So
Das heißt
Wir parsen uns das hier
Ach ne, das kann ich hier direkt dran machen, gell
So, hier hinten dran
Dann ist hier in Response ist das drin
Okay, dann printen wir die Response einmal
So, dann sagen wir
New Frontend API Response
Mir fällt echt kein dümmerer Name ein gerade
so gibt es die möglichkeit dass man das muss ich jetzt alles von hand mapen dass
ich jetzt irgendwie sage response so direkt geht net in dort nette
könnte ich jetzt sowas hier machen geht das ja auch
Nee, ne?
Oder?
Okay, Response.
User ID.
Was will er jetzt von mir?
May produce 0 Pro...
Warum?
Weil Response 0 sein könnte?
Gibt's in Java sowas?
Das ist nichts Null.
Spawns.
ID.
Title.
Spawns.
Completed.
Und jetzt kommt ein Timestamp.
Jetzt brauchen wir ein Timestamp.
Unix Timestamp.
Java generate Unix Timestamp.
Unique Time in Java.
System Current Time Millispl...
Easy.
So.
Es ist ein Long.
Okay.
So, jetzt haben wir hier unsere komische Klasse am Start dafür.
Message oder so.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie kriegen wir diese Klasse hier verschickt?
Kann man da auch einfach sagen, Message?
Ne.
Wie serialise ich das denn jetzt wieder als Message?
New?
Binary Message, Pong Message
Ich will keine Binary Message
Ich will eine Text Message
Aber ich würde gerne
Das serializen
Macht das Spring auch irgendwie für mich?
Du kannst es einfach returnen
Ne, anscheinend nicht
anscheinend nicht also gucken wir noch ob wir gucken mal schnell ob noch alles funktioniert
system out message aber ob das hier an sich funktioniert
ja und timestamp unix time und alles
ich habe keinen return tab es gibt hier nichts was return wird ich will das als als message an
alle meine frontend sachen schicken also ist jetzt wie wie serielle ist sehr realisiere ich
das denn schön dass chasen dass das spring magic macht aber spring serialize objekt to jason
auto sind objekt zu jason
Jason
Jackson
What the fuck
Pleon wieder.
Object Mapper.
Ah ne.
New Object Mapper.
Write.
Value.
Okay, kryptischer hätte man es jetzt ja nur wirklich nicht benennen können.
New Object Mapper Write Value.
Und da kommt dann am Ende ein serialisiertes Jason-Buy raus.
Also, die Benamung ist wirklich hängen geblieben.
Auch nicht besser.
wobei ich will ja gar kein egal will er da gar keine exception
schmeißen muss ich jetzt wieder try try catchen oder was
Jetzt muss das hier natürlich, wenn ich das hier brauche, muss das in das Trial rein.
mehr Einrückungstiefe, please.
So.
Jetzt kann ich das hier schicken.
Das ist jetzt nicht schön.
Das kann man bestimmt noch etwas verfeinern,
weil man versteht, was man da eigentlich macht.
So, aber jetzt müsste ich hier eigentlich
eine Antwort kriegen.
Ja.
Mit Timestamp.
Kunst.
Das ist, wenn du Java und C++ zusammenwurschtelst, ja.
Das funzt.
Wir kriegen jetzt alle Sekunde, also der ruft jetzt einmal in der Sekunde von der API was Neues ab,
packt noch einen Timestamp dabei und schickt es an mein Frontend zurück.
Heißt im Endeffekt auch, wenn wir jetzt hier in unser Frontend gehen,
Kriegen wir alle Sekunde eine Nachricht geschickt?
Guck mal, ich hatte gerade mehrfach 8 hintereinander.
So, und jetzt können wir das eigentlich anzeigen.
Also sprich, wir können jetzt sagen, onMessage, wir loggen das.
Und jetzt hören meine Vanilla-Java-Skript-Skills gerade auf.
Moment, wie würde ich das jetzt eigentlich machen?
div id ja keine ahnung content oder so und dann java javascript document get element by id content
und jetzt irgendwie inner html inner text gleich message
ach nee moment
Pass.
Message.
Ach, Data.
Ich check's immer noch nicht so ganz.
Ach ne, Moment. Text.
Ich muss da gar nichts chasen, parsen.
Ja.
Okay.
Für uns.
Wir kriegen per Websocket
einmal in der Sekunde neues Zeug geschickt.
Wir verzichten jetzt mal drauf, unser Frontend hübsch zu machen.
Darum geht es jetzt ja nicht.
Das klappt.
Also ich muss sagen, dass das deutlich einfacher ging, als ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Das hier ist nicht schön und das ist jetzt sicher bestimmt nicht Java, Business, Enterprise,
High IQ Zeug mäßig gemacht.
Gerade diese 500 mal Try ineinander finde ich schon ziemlich cringe.
wobei das brauchen wir doch gar nicht guck mal das try können wir uns sparen
weil wir jetzt das äußere haben so kann man mehrere exceptions eigentlich
catchen irgendwie so ne ja man muss ja mehrere catch blöcke machen wahrscheinlich
aber wir können einfach hier zack bumm so easy einfach mal alles ignorieren
mein pipe da wäre ich jetzt nicht drauf gekommen
wo man chat gpt fragen wie wir das hier hübscher machen können
Wie könnte man diese Methode, das ist ja eine Klasse, ist egal, hübscher machen?
Einige Codesmells, Leute!
Codesmells
JetGPT hat anscheinend gehört
dass ich mich 3-4 Tage nicht waschen darf
wegen meiner
Pflaster auf dem Rücken
Verletzung der Single Responsibility
Prinzip
Jetzt brauchen wir mal nicht übertreiben
hier jetzt flasche ich habe am donnerstag habe ich einen kleinen leberfleck raus geschnippelt
bekommen am rücken michael 50 milliarden wollen lange nicht gesehen und der doktor hat gesagt ich
soll das pflaster so lange wie es geht drauf lassen uns auf gar keinen fall soll wasser
dran kommen das heißt nach möglichkeit dahinter nicht wäschen oder nicht duschen gehen für so
lange wie ich aushalte ich habe mir gedacht bis montag halte ich aus das ist dann donnerstag
Freitag, Samstag, so vier Tag quasi.
Dann muss ich aber mal wieder...
Nutzt doch Cursor für die Entwicklung.
Nee.
Also Michael,
fünf Spiele an. Bei mir hat der Doktor gesagt,
du musst mir da keine Gedanken machen.
Da hat dein Kollege aber nochmal Glück gehabt,
dass das alles so...
so früh erkannt wurde, oder?
Wenn nicht Cursor, was sonst?
Einfach weniger Vibe coden.
Vierjähriges Jubiläum.
Das stand nirgendwo.
Wieso nutzt du Java?
Weil ich auf der Arbeit
eventuell demnächst ein bisschen Java
basteln muss.
muss ich habe mich da freiwillig freiwillig mache ich mache so ein 14 tage praktikum bei
unseren entwicklern ich nenne es mal praktikum habe ich gesagt will ich mal machen und da hätte
dachte ich mir es wäre vielleicht nicht verkehrt ein bisschen bisschen probleme bisschen was zu
wissen darüber wo ist das problem mit vibe coding wenn du weib code ist ohne zu verstehen was es
macht so also was sagt er denn jetzt rief die fakt dort
Will er mit Logger?
Geh weg.
Websocket Service?
What?
Alter, ChatGPT macht da wieder
ein super krasses Business Enterprise
Ding draus.
also ich weiß nicht so viel besser finde ich das jetzt nicht was chat gpt da gebastelt hat
außer dass es das alles ausgeklärt hat
würde es dann auch funktionieren ich bist gar nicht ausbricht also das finde ich ganz
gut was chat gpt macht das ist das finde ich in der tat tatsächlich sinnvoll und
zwar zu sagen dass man das was man hier mehrfach braucht dass man daraus
kann es das kann doch intelli j garantiert
So, ja.
Das finde ich tatsächlich ganz sinnvoll.
Einmal machen wir das.
Können wir das renamen?
Rename zu...
Ich weiß, das macht man im Java-Umfeld nicht,
aber ich finde das eigentlich mal ganz gut so.
Dass man...
dass man das Ding hier einmal global macht,
das macht natürlich schon irgendwo Sinn.
Ja.
Aber funzt alles.
Bin begeistert.
Ja, da haben wir unser Ziel für heute erreicht.
Websocket.
oder was ist das? Funktionierende Websocket-Anwendung
mit Spring Boot.
Geguckt, wie man
HTTP-Requests macht.
Und Chat, was sagt ihr?
Wie schlage ich mich für jemanden, der keinen Plan von Spring Boot
und Java hat? Ich finde, geht doch klar, oder?
Für die kurze Zeit.
ich habe jetzt nicht gefragt dass ich krass gelobt werde interessiert mich einfach nur
was sie davon denkt außerdem loben geht immer html file von spring so das hatten wir schon
das haben wir schon gemacht hier aber das blöde ist wenn das html ausgeliefert wird hier vom vom
tomcat dann muss ich jedes mal die anwendung neu starten
anhand einer sonstigen konings okay das heißt sonst programmiert immer totalen
schrott und heute war okay oder spring dev tools für hot reload das habe ich
gelesen im Tutorial, das reloadet
irgendwie alle 5 oder 10 Sekunden.
Das ist doch eklig.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen,
wenn man irgendein Frontend-Framework
benutzt mit Vite oder so für Hot Reload,
dann kann man das eh nicht ausliefern lassen.
Dann würde ich das eh so machen, dass ich
die Frontend-Anwendung halt so
entwickle und einen
Node.js Dev-Server laufen habe
und dann an mein Backend gehe und
erst wenn ich das Ding quasi
ausliefern will
im Endeffekt würde ich da eine statische Version bauen lassen und hier rein kopieren.
Swing UI. Swing, sieht das mittlerweile wenigstens ganz, ganz brauchbar aus.
sondern ich gehe jetzt eine runde joggen wird man echt wieder zeit habe zwei monate fast nichts gemacht
Überlegt noch ob ich meine fitness uhr anziehen soll oder nicht
weil wenn ich die uhr anziehe dann sehe ich erst mal wieder wie schlecht geworden bin deswegen lasse ich die uhr wahrscheinlich aus
Näh, Strava poste ich nicht.
Ich poste auch mein Fahrradzeug nicht auf Strava.
Das macht nix.
Soll nur kein Wasser drankommen.
Das Problem ist allerdings,
ihr sagt jetzt da was,
wenn ich mich bis Montag nicht gescheit wäschen darf,
wegen dem Pflaster und alles,
wenn ich jetzt rennen gehe,
dann wird das ja noch schlimmer.
Ja, dann muss ich vielleicht doch morgen schon.
ja waschlappen darf ich waschlappen darf ich das darf ich ja ich muss nur gucken
dass auf den rücken kein kein wasser kommt gut leute da sehen wir uns
vielleicht morgen früh zum aufwachen schrie mal gucken ob ich diese diese
woche ein hinbekomme wir hören uns bis dann macht's gut
See you!